[Applause]
let's paint a picture of an economy
on the one hand more jobs lower
unemployment higher wages and stock
markets but on the other hand
backups at ports and rail yards
companies struggling to meet demand
prices rising too much too fast it's the
story of the u.s in 2021 and the
historic return of inflation costs
rising across the country runaway costs
food gas electricity housing consumer
prices are made too high it came
gradually and then suddenly crude oil
prices crept higher than jumped in
february it was gasoline prices heading
into march than lumber and used cars in
april u.s consumer prices a key measure
of inflation have been climbing almost
every month since rising to 6.8 percent
in november the highest since 1982.
consumers when they're going to stores
are feeling it and here on the back end
when we're looking at a lot of this data
you can see it really rippling through
the economy so everything from
gas prices food prices raw goods lumber
or metals you're seeing those prices
going up often to multi-decade highs
there is plenty of argument about how it
happened and who's at fault but we know
it wasn't any one thing a fast and huge
rebound in spending was partly to blame
americans started buying things again
after holding back during the early
months of the pandemic using cash from
emergency government programs and as
demand was picking up a lot of companies
were slow to restart struggling to get
supplies and to bring people back to
work that plus outdated infrastructure
helped gum up production so fewer goods
and services available plus rising
demand equals higher prices the prices
are going all the way from the boat to
the port where they're often stuck to
the shipping companies and the
transportation companies who don't have
enough truck drivers to manufacturing
plants to the consumer now most
economists agree that the government
also had something to do with this both
the trump and biden administrations
passed spending bills that sent
trillions of dollars into the economy
through government agencies
infrastructure investment and by giving
money straight to americans and then of
course there's the federal reserve it
pumped even more cash into the economy
and cut rates to near zero making it
cheaper and easier for banks to borrow
and loan money all those factors
combined to help push inflation up to
where it is now too high uncomfortably
high multi-decade high today it's the
federal reserve more than anyone else
who could put the brakes on inflation
but it's taking its time and that's
because it's got a tough choice if it
puts the brakes on hard it would
probably reduce inflation but it could
also slow down or even stop the economic
recovery completely on the other hand
the fed could slowly lift its foot off
the gas and hope inflation mostly dies
down on its own that's what the fed's
been doing so far they're going to be
very careful and the federal reserve is
definitely keeping in mind that they're
working with an economy that is still
recovering one reason policymakers are
being so careful is that they don't want
to make the same mistake as last time
after the great recession some people
think the federal reserve hit the brakes
too soon and the recovery was weaker
than it could have been this time around
the more generous economic policy has
been largely successful all that money
the fed and the last two administrations
dumped into the economy is partly why
the recovery was so much stronger than
after 2008 and why it's been faster in
the us than in other major economies
really there's been a huge recovery a
huge v-shaped recovery the u.s recovery
will continue being stronger u.s growth
recovery and continued strength looks
more positive than we see in the rest of
the developed world we're experiencing
the strongest economic recovery in the
world so what does that all mean for us
well no matter what happens we're likely
to have high inflation for at least the
next few months economists are expecting
prices to rise 3.7 next year still above
the two percent that the fed is aiming
for but that's lower than it has been
and as energy costs pull back and supply
chain issues improve there are signs
inflation should start easing up we are
pretty much at peak
inflation from the supply chain issues
right now already starting to see some
moderation of some of the inflation
pressures signs that some of these
supply shocks are loosening up we're
past the peak inflation in terms of
markets pricing that in you've reached
the peak and passed the peak in
inflation hysteria in the end the truth
is we don't know what happens next
plenty of investors and economists got
the inflation call wrong the first time
and it could catch us by surprise again
but we do know that a dangerous price
spiral leading to an economic meltdown
is pretty unlikely the federal reserve
should be able to step in and keep
things from getting out of hand if
prices keep rising too much too fast and
when we paint that picture of the us
economy that's got a problem we also
have to see that it's just part of the
story there's another picture the
opposite side of the same coin one that
shows a record-setting recovery blowing
past the global competition faster
growth more money and more jobs all made
possible by the same decisions and
policies that helped push inflation
higher
one of these two pictures will probably
define the post-pandemic era for
economists in the new year we'll see
which one
[Music]
you